MAX SALTONSTALL:
Welcome to BeyondCorp
in a Bottle, where
we explore journeys
into the world of context-aware
access and zero trust networks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Slager Bank and Trust,
like many large enterprises
with a long history
of IT infrastructure,
turned to a perimeter
security model
early on to keep their
corporate resources safe.
All the good stuff--
customer info, company
data, internal applications,
et cetera--
had to be protected.
So they built walls--
proxies, firewalls,
and other barriers--
to keep the public
internet separated
from their private systems.
That left employees with two
options to get work done--
sit in Slager offices
or connect via VPN.
They wanted to do better, both
for security and usability.
Having recently learned
about context-aware,
they decided to give it a try.
But how to start?
To kick it off,
the Slager IT team
did a broad survey of
their existing systems
and applications.
They identified Lumen, an
internal marketing analytics
app, as an ideal candidate to
test out context-aware access.
They picked Lumen because
it had a very specific use
case for a specific set
of people at the company,
and had few outside
dependencies.
It already ran on the web, so
required no platform migration
work.
To ensure success, the Slager
team also got leadership buy-in
early on from IT, security,
and marketing teams
so the top management
knew why they were doing
this and the project timeline.
They explained the benefits
of increased access
for employees outside the
office and for partner agencies,
while also addressing risks
of unauthorized access
or application compromise.
They began by getting
Lumen running on GCP,
in their case, using
Compute Engine VMs instead
of their on-premise VMs.
Once that was up
and running, they
could activate
Identity-Aware Proxy
as part of the
HTTPS load balancer
in front of the cluster.
They created simple rules in
IAP to allow the marketing team
to view the web app and the
IT team to manage access.
Then they started
shifting traffic
from their on-prem instance
of Lumen to the GCP instance,
watching carefully for errors.
The Slager team enjoyed a
couple other side benefits
from this shift.
They got multi-region
availability, reduced latency
for workers away
from headquarters,
and they were able to open
up Lumen to specific agency
vendors who had wanted for
years to use the same analytics
platform to collaborate better
with the internal marketing
teams.
After the successful first step,
the Slager Bank and Trust IT
team had gained both
expertise and confidence
in using GCP and IAP
together and began
to plan future migrations
for other internal services.
To get more detail, check out
my blog post, linked below,
for step-by-step instructions
and subscribe for more videos
on context-aware access.
When it comes to protecting your
company, keep your data yours.
[MUSIC PLAYING]